we're starting off with Professor Maxim
rubinski from the University of Illinois
Urbana
he needs no introductions
um
thank you
it's uh it's great to be here seeing all
these faces that I haven't seen in the
same room since 2019
it's also good that finally everybody is
working on learning theory
because 15 year 15 years ago was like
the only information theorist who worked
on learning theory and now I'm more of a
control theorist but I still do
information Theory and here I am anyway
so this is this is Joint work with my
graduate student
who was actually an undergrad at
Illinois and then he uh decided to stay
because that's how fabulous it is in the
corn fields
um
so he's really ramped up in fact uh just
just recently there are three papers of
his uh up on archive including this one
so uh so let me uh kind of get right
into it
so so uh
there will be connections to to what you
heard in in Taurus uh
um keynote having to do with codes
having to do with uh with complexity of
uh um complexity of various uh spaces
and uh the interplay between these so
um I mean it's about so so so the topic
here is suprema of random processes
which sounds very dry and probabilistic
and it is but uh I'll explain
um briefly why learning theories should
care about this or why information
theories should care about this but the
setting is like this we have a
stochastic process
XT here T is symmetric space which I
assume to be compact the process is
centered so zero mean and we're
interested in in Upper bounding the
expected supremum of XT
and we want the upper and lower bounds
in terms of some measures of complexity
of T here the idea is that as a function
of T the random variables may be
correlated and if they're correlated or
let's say values of T and T Prime that
are nearby you could say something about
x d versus XD Prime and if there's a lot
of structure in this you can actually
exploit this to say something about this
this bound like for example uh if if T
is a finite set uh and all uh all the
XDS are independent then a very simple
argument shows that you you should only
expect something on the order of square
root of log T to be the supremum and
this is you know a log of uh of of of a
cardinality appears and uh you know CS
theorists will immediately say that this
is information theoretic
true every time there's like a log of
something yeah it's information to read
entropy but um but uh um it turns out
that you can actually uh relate it to to
entropy like quantities even when um T
is not finite or when uh XCS are not
independent
and this just lists uh a variety of
applications so for example if you open
this book by Michelle Telegraph called
upper and lower bounds for stochastic
processes you'll see all these
applications
in the context of learning theory where
you would expect to see something like
this is when you're trying to analyze
let's say the behavior of
something like empirical risk
minimization and uh you use something
called symmetrization you end up with a
quantity called the Rademacher average
uh here of course I stylized it and I
removed all the complexity all the
structure that that comes from learning
all it is here is just a standardized
sum of uh random variables these Epsilon
i's are just random minus one plus one
bits and TI's are coordinates of a
vector T and this Vector will come from
let's say losses of some hypothesis on
your training data and it turns out that
controlling the size of this process is
uh closely related to
things like generalization error of
imperialist minimization and here the
metric of course is just the euclidean
norm on these
unuses and T's and this is why I
normalize it one over root n as opposed
to one over n
um Okay so
um
the main result
that I state in a very old-fashioned
form actually I'll explain a little bit
later why this is old-fashioned is uh
really um
coming from the uh from from the work of
uh um Xavier fernique in the 70s and
then Michelle telegrond uh really you
know building up on this in the 80s and
90s and here's the idea so so let's
suppose our process has what you call
subgaussian increments and this is
exactly what I what I was referring to
and I said well there could be some some
measure of closeness uh between the
elements of the underlying index set
this metric D and that could be
reflected in the closeness of the
corresponding uh random variables making
up this process we assume that compared
to d uh between s and t the increment XS
minus XT is stochastically small it's uh
so the ratio is is nice and subgaussian
and if that's the case then you have the
following bounds
so here this T naught is just for uh the
the it's a nice trick you if you if you
consider um
if there's no absolute value here you
just subtract a fixed T naught then the
supremum of X D minus XD naught as
always
non-negative
um I mean because so this expected
Supreme was always non-negative but then
at least you're dealing with a bunch of
non-negative random variables so then
you hope that
really the most sophisticated inequality
you need is markov's inequality and a
lot of Ingenuity which is basically the
case so it turns out that turns out that
uh the upper bound is like this there's
this functional which depends on a
probability measure mu on your index
space d think about as a prior if you're
a Bayesian or a weight
your friends are offended uh and T is an
element of that space and and what you
do is you integrate square roots of this
log of one over uh the probability of a
ball of radiuseppelin around t uh the
square root of log of 1 over X really I
mean if you look at the inverse of this
function you see why but the point is
that this quantity if you now take the
soup over T's and then if over these
prior weights you get an upper bound
um and you know and this integral is you
know how are you supposed to compute
that right I mean you're looking at
measures of of of of balls in the metric
space it's hard to deal with
but it turns out to be tight uh for
example if your process is gaussian and
the metric is actually just the
canonical covariance Matrix metric then
you can actually reverse this so This
lower bound holds this was proved by
Target around in 1987.
um and you know since then of course uh
um there were you know lots of um
um lots of improvements so nobody wanted
to deal with these things uh by the way
their majorizing measure comes from the
definition that for me can telegram used
this if if if probability measure mu on
your on your metric space is such at
this point he's finite or the Supreme of
this quantity is fine I think all the
major Rising measures majorizes the
process
but you know so then nobody wanted to
work with them and and and and the
results became sort of phrased in terms
of various combinatorial things
covering and packing trees changing over
admissible sequences telegram even had a
paper called majorizing measures without
measures
um but uh but but then you know if you
look at this if you're an information
theorist and you see like yeah if you're
a computer scientist log n is like okay
entropy but log of one over probability
if you're an information Theory it's
like oh this is Shannon coding and uh
and Andreas Maurer is just one of my
heroes because you know his biography if
you if you read like his his papers in
the transactions and information
theories two lines it says he's an
independent scholar with an interesting
information in in probability and
learning theory because I think he uh
um he patented some computer vision
algorithms and I think he also owns like
either an olive uh you know um Olive
Tree Grove or Vineyard or something like
that so he's you know he's a man of
means who can like do all this stuff so
anyway so he wrote he wrote this he you
know he posted a preprint on his webpage
that I was kind of obsessed with for a
long time until I handed the right
student who who could make sense of it
uh he basically said if you look at this
this is basically a number of bits you
know it's kind of obvious right I mean
you you give me a prior Mew and and this
is how many bits you need to tell me to
localize an element T to accuracy
Epsilon and then you know and then of
course with that you say oh okay but uh
but if if T is finite or discrete which
if T is compact is just approximated by
the speed set however large you want
then using this correspondence between
pose and measures the craft McMill
inequality and information Theory we can
you know spin all sorts of tales about
how in fact the bounded boundedness of
expected suprema is Maurer said it's
equivalent to the existence of efficient
codes for the elements of T it basically
means that there exists at least one
measure mu such that I assign it to the
elements of T is a prior and uh and
actually all the elements of T can be
described using nice codes and then
there's also this multi-scale
construction right because what you're
doing is you're actually averaging over
uh over a whole bunch of different
distortions up the diameter of t
so uh in this work we kind of took this
up
Maury did not prove the lower bound and
his constructions are
uh are somewhat hard to parse if you're
an information Theory so I wanted to
phrase it more familiar information
theoretic language and see if uh if if
something interesting comes out of that
so so we're gonna work with uh basically
this idea that I just want to see how
well I'm doing now okay okay
cool
um right so so we're working as I said
on the metric space sorry but you only
have 23. yeah that's fine oh that's
perfect
um so we have a we have a metric space
right that's that's that that's the
that's the set that indexes are random
process elements think about it as maybe
you know I mean these days everybody
works with neural Nets so key is
actually uh you know subset of a high
dimensional euclidean space listing all
the weights of your neural Nets or I
don't know your attention matrices or
whatever it is that kid these days do
um but the point is it's it's a compact
metric spaces it's a finite diameter
just set it to one
and we're going to look at variable
length codes uh that are lossy right so
so in other words it's we have it we we
basically have
um we have a quantizer
Pi it maps elements of T to elements of
T but it has countable range so it's
your so so the image of t under Pi is
your code book
um and then each element in a code book
is associated to a binary string using a
uniquely decodable code
and we know that uh uniquely decodable
codes have to satisfy crafts inequality
right so this is the usual thing these
are binary binary links and then we're
going to say that this code Pi F
operates at resolution row if uh if the
error or Distortion in reconstructing
any element of T using a code is less
than or equal to row for old T so these
are codes where you have a guaranteed
Distortion and the only thing you care
about is is is is length notice that
there's no probabilistic description
here yet
there's no there's no Source model this
is just these are just codes the idea
behind
all these methods like generic changing
major Rising measures Etc which is
something that malware pointed out is
that what you really want is
either a single code that gives you very
very long binary strings but you can it
has this kind of a successive refinement
property you give me longer and longer
strings I can local localize the
elements of key better and better and
better or you can actually give a
sequence of codes and glue them together
into a single code either way we want to
work with sequences of codes so we're
going to call a sequence of such codes
admissible if the following three
properties hold
so there's this kind of a
markup structure so if I know
um
the representation of Ft at K plus one
level in the hierarchy I don't need to
know T I can just construct I can
degrade it to to the one below it
deterministically
um eventually the codes will give me
full reconstruction
so essentially uh as I keep going deeper
deeper into the sequence I I reconstruct
each element perfectly and finally uh
well I mean this is kind of the you know
the descriptions have to get more and
more informative
right and there are lots of ways of
constructing this Mara in in fact like
this is what we instruct extracted from
ours paper he has a very very clever
construction where he doesn't need
anything other than a probability
measure on your uh on your set T assume
T is countable and from that probability
measure you extract various elements you
basically construct a sequence of codes
in a very nice canonical way but you can
also go the other way you can go bottom
up you choose an increasing sequence of
finite partitions of T so it means that
basically each element of the partition
at level K plus one is this joint Union
of partition elements at the level below
it choose a unique representative in
each partition cell
right your usual quantization right take
take Pi KT the the the the you know code
uh element of t to the representative of
the cell that it's in and of course you
have the nesting property
and uh right so so the you know you can
also introduce the zeroth level as just
the trivial zero rate code
and then all these things are nested so
that's precisely this whole successive
kind of refinability thing and then you
can you know you can assign code links
in whatever way you choose for example
you can choose the probability measure
corresponding to the partition elements
just assign probabilities to partition
cells in a k and for each partition cell
have a conditional probability
distribution given that you're not
partition cell to refine to the next
level right so you can just keep going
um so that's just one way like I said
Mars paper from 2010 has a really really
clever construction
um that ifang and I are going to
describe in in a journal version of this
work
um
yeah
start with an automatic complexity and
to me that's like a dispersion that the
loss in the hypothesis starts and all of
that you know all this environment
one number and you wanted another bound
on that that's where you started and
then you said there's a lot of something
yes it reminds us of something else and
therefore I'm going to take my space
right but aren't you looking for enough
about I'm sort of missing that
connection how are you
is this a way of representing the
functional space itself yes it is that's
precisive it is you're not coding exits
you're coding tees right okay so so this
is an upper bound using codes
so here we have a sub gaussian process
and then you know just just take any
admissible sequence of codes
and then take a probability distribution
p on on integers which you need
um you can think about a sort of a
um I'll explain one way to interpret
that uh it's not exactly a a prior all
you can think about it as sort of a
mixing weights for a multi-scale
representation but the point is that
these C and PR are just three variables
that you can you can optimize over and
then with high probability
with high probability the difference
between x t and x d naught again this is
just needed for for the changing
argument to go through
um is upper bounded by the following sum
so you you sum overall your levels
and then row K minus 1 of course is a
distortion at level K minus one and
these are some and you can think about
this this uh
this log is natural log
this is the code length plus another log
of 1 over p k
um which in the theorem it's needed for
the union bound to go through but
operationally you'll see that there's a
mixture uh representation the point is
that this is this is a kind of a it
looks unwieldy
but I'll explain
um where the key idea of the proof is
the main idea really comes from this
paper of Mara we just uh noticed a few
things that you know he
didn't and and streamlined a few things
here's the idea so we're going to assume
that t is finite without loss of
generality T is Compact and a process is
separable you can just approximate
and then because T is uh finite
eventually you're going to hit the level
in your hierarchy where Pi KT is just
going to keep returning t
and that means that for each for each
element of your space t are your index
at T you can you can write your x t
minus x t naught and the Tina is just
some fixed Point
um as this kind of a changing
decomposition this is a starting point
in all of the works using you know using
these names like this is telegram's uh
idea which he attributes to komogorov
and some
sense
right and so of course at each level
let's look at what happens to just the
elements in the code book at level K
right so so remember that uh s is in the
code book level K I can construct the
corresponding element in the code book
of level K minus one the lower
resolution right below it without
knowing yes without knowing the it
rather right so I can just and so these
things are are basically just bounded
like that right just because because uh
because of nestedness of all the sets uh
with high probability but of course you
know these hold individually with high
probability than you to string them
together using Union bound and when you
do that you end up with this kind of a
thing and so then that's where you so so
PK is needed
um basically you know you scale a
probability for this event by DK and
then you use the fact that these when
you take the exponential of that and sum
them up you get one from Craft MacMillan
et cetera Etc
the points you get this bound and that's
the proof but I want to actually
operationalize it a little bit
so so as I said what does it have to do
with majorizing measures where where
star grants working in all of this uh
here's the idea take a sequence of codes
take this P which is just this kind of
instrumental
just collection of Weights that piece
not definitely I wouldn't dignify by
calling it the priority these are
weights
um and then consider the following
mixture so what you do is the what you
do is you you consider all the levels at
once
uh you assign Pro you're assign weight
PK to level okay and this is just uh and
this simply is the probability measure
corresponding to to the code book at
level K just using using the construct
construction and crust right because the
the quantity in the craft sum is a sub
probability measure that's what that's
what unique decodability means and I can
just normalize it
and then you can actually you know then
from this you can basically just
canonically extract the sequence of
partitions such that if I were to look
at the probability assigned to element t
um when I look at it at this resolution
of at level K the description length of
that is basically the description length
of this code plus that and the reason
why we need this is is for this whole
thing when I Stitch it together to to
give me uh to give me uh a bona fide uh
uniquely decodable code and so you see
that the operational interpretation is
that for any such mu
the expected suprema of a process
is
um is bounded by the following
quantities you look at your elements of
your underlying index set and for each
set you you sum up the resolution at
scale K times the square root of the
description length for T at level K
square root of log of 1 over the
probability again that comes from the
sub gaussian assumption
right you can put you know other
assumptions on the Tails and based on
that you would have instead of you know
power one half you would have power one
over P for some e bigger than one
right okay so so this is this is
interesting but there's an even better
result that basically says well you know
why am I even bothering with with these
multi-scale constructions the idea is
that if I know what happens at scale K
minus one remember can I success it can
I refine it to scale K and it turns out
that yes that actually you can the point
is that for convenience let's suppose
that uh the errors of of these uh code
decrease exponentially with K so take
like row K to be like 2 to the minus K
which is a standard construction and in
telegrams work
um just take uh you know and then and
then give uh exponentially decaying
weights to all the levels and then you
can just uh manipulate stuff and use
subativity of square root to end up with
this kind of a bound so the constant
game here comes from the fact that all
you're doing is just summing a geometric
series
um and it doesn't matter the interesting
thing is this so this is the Distortion
and this you can see that this is uh
this is the excess length that you have
to provide in order to localize T to a
better level of description given uh the
description at level K minus one and so
then and then the idea is that actually
for any for any majorizing measure for
any prior a new in any sequence of
partitions you can always construct a
sequence of codes such that this
quantity is actually upper bounded but
something by something more interesting
and this is exactly the difference in
code lengths uh in the Shannon code and
these quantities of course then then you
can then you can convert this into into
Riemann sums into integrals and you can
actually get the bound
um that appeared in the majorizing
measures
a lot of times for questions
um okay so so so this is nice and we we
in fact have a lot of examples where we
where we can you know just give you
different ways of constructing these
uh there are there are there are just uh
any strategy for constructing these kind
of sequential sequential
multi-resolution codes that give you
something something interesting and we
have some examples where we just recover
a whole lot of existing bounds
um
but the interesting thing is this lower
bound
right so because uh because it's it's
the lower Bound for for gaussian
processes that that was kind of that was
proved by telegram
um in 1987 using majorizing measures and
like I said you know you know he found
he found partition based uh techniques
so can we have a coding interpretation
for that and it turns out that we can
um and it looks like this
so now this is a gaussian process zero
mean and my metric but this is important
this metric has to be the covariance
covariance uh metric right so
um and if that's the case then for any
so here R uh has to be large enough
um such that you you build a sequence of
codes
at resolutions R minus K these so so
previously the codes you know could be
arbitrary here uh you construct a
specific sequence of codes
section this lower bound holds notice
that previously we had R to the minus K
plus one here we have R and minus K but
R eventually when you want to
approximate this by integrals
you take R to be like five or whatever
it's just a constant because you know
all the other powers of R will get
sucked into the integral and they will
no longer uh no longer matter because
the the whole point is that here you
want to show that these upper bounds and
lower bounds hold up to multiplicative
constants but once again you see this
interesting thing that
uh this quantity having to do with codes
is for gaussian processes fundamental
and that has to do with the fact I mean
so if you kind of squint and try to
explain why uh you would expect
something like this well
um gaussians have this nice property
that it doesn't matter whether whether
you're Beijing or frequent just or
whether you're doing you know complexity
regularization because negative log
likelihood of a gaussian is a quadratic
function and and then you also get this
log determinant so so so those things uh
so you're doing these squares but you
can also pretend that you're doing some
you know Bayesian regularized
optimization or you know or or you're
doing some sort of complexity penalty or
whatever right so so the point is that
somehow there's this very natural
relation between uh you know gaussians
their log probabilities
um code links and this this is also the
basis of various things like AIC or you
know resonance earlier ideas or Andrew
Marin's ideas and then and then also
because we're here uh we're working with
Galaxy and processes
uh this would immediately translate into
um into distances in in our space right
because the covariances are taken to be
the the inducing the metric
okay so so I'm gonna explain the proof
um
some detail
um not too much because I mean it it it
does get very hairy but the point is
that this is this was first proved by
tall ground in 1987 using majorising
measures and then you know later you
know telegram that you know he basically
said oh you know what I did in like 10
years ago is not good enough I'm gonna
reprove it using another method
um so he proved that using partitions no
measure is appearing and and vital
birdners
um had another argument where he said
well you can kind of have an argument
that uses both partitions and measures
because it brings back the original
Spirit of of all these results let me
briefly explain how it's proof
um
so so let me you know by G of a g for
Gauss obviously uh the Supreme when I
only look at elements of of a which is
some subset of t
so we're going to do the following we're
going to we're going to uh we're going
to
construct a partition
or sequence of partitions in a
particular way
these partitions so tala Grande was a
greedy procedure the idea is that
um you you look at your current your
constructed your current partition you
take an element in that partition and
then you basically cover it by balls of
of radius 2 to the minus K so you're at
level K and then you basically start
peeling off the ones that you know
peeling up the ones that give you the
largest value of G
and then uh and then so so you peeled
off a set intersected with a remove that
keep going you're going to stop
eventually because your your space is
Compact and it has a has bounded packing
and covering numbers so so so the idea
is that and then you repeat it for all
the elements in the partition in such a
way that there's there's going to be a
certain relation between these gas
in a set a at a partition level K and
it's children in the next level and this
relationship comes from a very
fundamental result that only holds for
galaxians called sudakov generation
um and basically just says that you know
there's there's a relationship between
GA and then the uh G's of its
descendants plus a correction that has a
square root log cardinality and the
cardinality in there is basically the
number of steps you you use in this
greedy procedure
um the point is that you end up with
this partition in this partition uh
somehow keeps track of of the growth of
these gas in the very you know very very
precise way and then you know they don't
want to construct a code
so so basically the main thing is really
constructing these code lanes because Pi
case you have a partition at level K
just pick a point and each partition
element that's your code book
but now of course remember that there's
first of all there's nestedness right if
I have if I have a which is a set at
level K and I have its descendants at
level K plus one
um
then then you want to keep track of the
number of descendants for each set
and when you do that you say okay if I
already could assign lengths at level K
I can assign Links at level K plus 1 by
simply telling you
which of the descendants of akt you're
in this ik Pi KT is basically the number
of
um of the set containing Pi KT that was
assigned to it using this greedy
Construction
and of course you know the you know here
the idea is that the uh the sum of 1
over N squared as you somewhere as you
sum over a lens is finite
right so
so that way you you know you basically
keep assigning these code links and you
satisfy crafting quality of each level
you end up with this sequence of codes
and you see that this uh the the main
thing really is that the excess length
here is actually proportional to log of
the number of steps you took in this
partition which is precisely that error
term
in the pseudocophony quality which I'm
not going into so this is this is the
key inequality that you know you can see
in the work of Telegraph and that noise
we just connected it to codes like I
said here here what's happened what's
happening is your level K but you have
to look at the level below and a level
above
so you're going to have to skip a level
so so basically for any point t
uh this Galaxy and supremum of the set
containing T at level K minus one plus a
slack C is a constant
even
write it down
five six seconds
um and and so then you skip a level
which is accounted for here this is the
excess length when when you go from
level K minus one level okay and then
again because of the nestedness of all
these sets and this pseudocoff
inequality that you use you end up with
this kind of abound and then you know
this is then you do exactly what
telegram that betnurs did you you can
you can basically just um iterate you
use induction so when K is equal to one
this is a zero t a zero key is the
entire set so you have G of T which is
which is what you want at the lower
bound but it's lower bounded in terms of
in terms of you know the the the points
and successive levels of refinement so
you need to kind of you know do this for
a0k and then one a one key then sum and
then after you sum you you end up with
with this quantity
so the point is that uh I mean I think I
think I think I was able to describe
what's going on you know more or less
you know accurately the the main idea
really is that there is this there is
this partitioning that that somehow
respects you know the the Growth
Properties of this of these Galaxy and
suprema and then all we really do is
keep careful track of awareness
partitioning you are and you can
actually use that to construct a code
that's basically the idea
okay
well I think I can summarize
uh and then I'll briefly tell you where
you know I think this this should go or
could go the main thing really is the
following we have you know the main the
main object of interest is a process
right think about as a generalization
error of a learning algorithm or rather
Market complexity or what have you the
process is zero mean it has these sub
gaussian increments
um another piece of the picture is a
variable length code which is a lossy
code with a variable length
representation
right so we assume that
um there's a distortion and the
Distortion between T and its image under
the code is no more than real so for a
sequence of such codes we associate this
quantity that keeps track of the
Distortion occurred
right so this is Distortion in in going
from level K minus one to level K and
this is the excess length and going from
level K minus one to level okay and now
we showed that while this quantity
actually uh turns out to if you don't
want to talk about measures
you can talk about codes
as uh as we know as information
theorists so so the upper bound is is
this right minimize over codes well
sequence of codes maximize over points
and for the for the gaussian processes
Bond could be reversed and really the
you know the main idea which I think is
something that Maura pointed out and I
think this is very fruitful is that well
you should actually think about learning
algorithms as random measures on your on
your uh on your on your set T and if
that's the case then then you can think
about a learning algorithm
if you let's say you know discretize
your hypothesis space learning algorithm
science weights or or likelihoods or
whatever you want to call it to to the
elements of the hypothesis space that
gives you a code so these codes can
actually
um
you know you can use it in various
Frameworks like maybe let's say
there's this term called zero shot
learning and that's basically like you
pre-trained on some data and then you
you know you you and then you just take
that and just minimally tweak it and
then you have performance on some on
some unrelated uh well on some different
but but possibly related set of data
where you can think about the the uh the
distribution over your hypothesis space
as coming from this
um uh previous sort of some previous
training and not distribution already
encode some some quote-unquote prior or
or code uh or gives you a description
link for for each hypothesis
okay so I'll stop here
um and take questions and well if you
want to see the details that's on
archive and ifang is also going to give
a virtual talk at um isi key this summer
minutes to two questions
yeah yeah so yeah excellent Xbox so one
question is about uh we have a
construction with this VLC post British
soil
uh foreign
recently where we said well
you can just take any so basically a
random process and then you have and you
select one of the keys randomly based on
some data so now you look at the
expectation of x capital T well X Tau I
guess 1000 random variable so can you
actually uh because you know soup is
just a particular random variable which
extracts and maximize
thanks I think I actually give this yeah
very naive one yes can I tie that to do
this inequality
uh well done listening quality is not
tight I mean that's like basically so
our upper bounds will give you w so you
you we apply that oh yeah I mean but but
that least bound is like I said it's
just known to be not tight it's just the
reason why people use doubly is because
you don't need anything if you just have
that integral and you have the you know
bounce and covering numbers oh you just
like calculus to compute these things
but in many cases it just it's just
you know just wildly off but yeah I mean
these these all these bounds will give
you doubles
because once you have majorizing
measures from that from from that is
doubly follows
the difference is that you can compute
often yes
thanks
any other questions
thank you Rex
[Music]